i just got four pieces of cheese cut up
in a small bowl
son the posture is right there you know
what i'm saying yo what's he going on
i'ma get myself a piano
um
[Music]
uh damn
you know i've wanted a piano for a long
time so i'm gonna have that [ __ ]
i'm gonna give you this serving right up
i get moving baby i get you know ricky's
doing gas
body gas
[Music]
doing gas body gas and fighting
bangers baby oh a lot of irish men and
women as they age they got the same tits
on them if you notice that they said
they similarly jugged up
yo what's going on i'm gonna get myself
a
um
[Music]
you know it's that man pewter you know
that compumen
ricky's [ __ ] up
ricky's licking snakes
ricky's doing gas
body gas fighting
you know fighting
doing gas
body gas and fighting
ricky's doing gas
body gas
[Music]
baby i'm gonna give you this serving
right up with that vestibule of seed
baby that weiner god i love that um yo
what's going on i'm gonna get myself a
piano uh
[Music]
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy
two
options watch one this one or this one
you